[Musik]
jäger auf der flucht vor seinem hochsitz
ein landwirt entdeckt eine wasserader
[Musik]
und ein autorennen auf dem feld die
ostdeutschen tobis inzwischen kult jagen
einen modernen es juli
das alles sind inszenierungen höhe
vorbeifahrende züge zum teil der
kunstaktion bewegt das land
auf einer 30 kilometer lange zugstrecke
zwischen naumburg und sachsen anhalt und
jena in thüringen machen die anwohner
theater für die reisenden dass man ist
immer nur aufs handy oder dem bildschirm
schauen sie nun wirklich einmal bewusst
in die landschaft blickt die größe ist
zauberhaft und natürlich die einzelne
beiträge wieder in die landschaft
gestellt werden sind schon speziell
macht gute laune
ein paar kilometer weiter basteln
anwohner noch an den requisiten als bush
getan
gehen sie in stellung das feld ist ihre
bühne
der auftritt wird nur wenige sekunden
dauern diese verwunderung und diese
überraschung diesem moment gehen wollen
wir den zuschauern bieten und damit sie
sich auch freuen sich diebisch auf
einmal uns drin
die verwirkung der zuschauer ist ein
grundkonzept eher auf
was ist echt was ist inszeniert mal
scheint ein baum zu brennen
mal bevölkern steinzeitmenschen die
gegend
oder ein hai greift an
[Musik]
ausgedacht haben sich das hirn hinter
und jakob medienkünstler und professorin
für experimentelle television
vor was sie vor 15 jahren hätte man sich
nicht vorstellen können dass man
sozusagen das internet so bildersuche
macht und 15.000 bilder durchschnittlich
am tag so als sand nails anguckt ja das
macht ja total was mit mit einem selbst
und das ist für uns eigentlich so dieses
zug fahren ja obwohl es ja eigentlich
schon fast ein altes transportmittel ist
heutzutage ist für uns ein bisschen die
analogie dazu zu diesen neuen medien
man fällt also an ganz schnell in sachen
vorbei guckt sie sich nicht richtig an
aber es sind laut asus am thema vorbei
hunderte freiwillige machen mit in dem
kleinen dorf dem britschen sind fast
alle einwohner auf den beinen und ihren
lagern die idee
sie sind auf augenhöhe mit den reisenden
und schauen zurück in den zug
es ist natürlich schön wenn was los ist
wenn unsere einwohner auch mitmachen
können partizipieren
da also erst mal ein schönes wochenende
und das war einfach dass man sieht es
ist ein sehr besonderer landstreicher
ist jetzt nicht wirklich groß bekannt
also noch ein bisschen geheimtipp aber
vielleicht zieht es den ein oder anderen
dann doch hierher die züge passieren
neun bahnhöfe und überall
ich weiß nur gott singt ein chor in die
offene bakom toten
hier startet auch rocco einen wettlauf
gegen die suche der trick 25 identisch
gekleidet die läufe erwecken den
eindruck der mensch sei schneller als
die maschine
[Musik]
für die macher eine auseinandersetzung
mit dem thema mobilität und
geschwindigkeiten für die läufer vor
allem ein großer spaß und ein kleines
stück völkerverständigung so etwas in
einer gruppe zu machen und ich wollte
mehr über die lokale kultur erfahren
für mich als ausländerin war es möglich
den rasenden rocco hat er natürlich
die akteure spielen insgesamt 24 züge 1
2 aufführungstagen für die rennen in
büsche heißt das zwei mal pro stunde
über spitze
wir kannten uns vorher alle nicht ja und
ich finde das unheimlich spannend also
das ist heute nette leute kennenlernen
spaß haben und ich denke mal das ist
auch so die sache von dieser von dieser
aktion das man halt mit anderen leuten
gemeinsam das gute inszenierungen für
vorbeifahrende züge eine kunstaktion die
die bewohner in bewegung versetzt und
die zugreisenden in kürze
[Musik]